okay just wanted to say hi and thank you  all I appreciate your viewership your  generosity I wouldn't be able to do so  without you I say that I believe in  every single episode and I mean that who  the heck would have thought people would  be interested in two hour three hour  four hour five hour conversations on  metaphysics on ontology on epistemology  on physics like hardcore theoretical  physics and I forgot to mention that  coming up is Donald Hoffman and John  graviki so watch out for a community  post of a request for questions again  thank you thank you I'll be testing out  doing this more just as a test and if it  doesn't work in terms of Engagement in  terms of what you all think in terms of  how I feel about it as well then we'll  see what happens but for now thank you  thank you thank you my wife is in the  washroom and our anniversary is coming  up so I better get back to her if I want  to continue to have more anniversaries